yesterday we learned that Republican
Senator Rand Paul is the first senator
to contract coronavirus Rand Paul's
staff tweeting out yesterday quote
Senator Rand Paul has tested positive
for kovat 19 he's feeling fine and is in
quarantine
he's asymptomatic and was tested out of
an abundance of caution due to his
extensive travel and events he was not
aware of any direct contact with any
infected person now despite not being
aware that he had contact with an
infected person as an infected person
himself there are reports that he went
to the Senate gym to work out after
being tested but before receiving the
results his staff was asked about it and
they said he didn't go anywhere after
getting his positive test result which
of course wasn't the question the
question was did he go to the gym after
being tested on a an abundance of
caution but before the results and it
appears that he did but what we do know
is he had lunch with a whole bunch of
Republican senators including Mitt
Romney and so Mitt Romney yesterday said
the following and Paul has been
diagnosed with kovin 19 wish him the
very best he's compromised given health
conditions he's had in the past and so
we'll be praying for him and thinking of
thinking about it and of course all the
senators are going to seek medical
advice as to what action we should take
to make sure that we don't in any way
spread this virus ourselves yes yes we
were in lunch together with Rand and
hope he's doing very well but we have to
determine whether any of us should self
quarantined as a result of being in the
same room and indeed shortly thereafter
we learned that Mitt Romney himself is
self quarantine now Donald Trump during
yesterday's lie riddled gongshow
propaganda press briefing was told that
Romney was in quarantine and Trump
sarcastically says oh gee that's too bad
with a doofy look on his face of course
dripping with sarcasm Trump known not to
like Mitt Romney for a while and in
particular since Mitt Romney voted to
convict Donald Trump on impeachment on
one of the two counts check this out and
Trump actually asked whether
with sarcasm - which Trump sarcastically
responds
oh no no no sarcasm here welcome on top
of Senator Paul now four senators are in
isolation and the rules say that in
order to vote senator Rick Scott also
two of them word contact with Rick is
going on with the critical stimulus
package vote expect Romney's imagination
Trump barely able to contain his Glee
that a political adversary of his might
be infected with life-threatening
illness remember Mitt Romney 73 years
old certainly at risk of a serious case
of coronavirus if he were to catch it
and Trump says gee that's too bad
sarcastically note that Trump made this
comment about Romney after he bragged
during the same press conference that he
had done this amazing job uniting
Democrats and Republicans and bringing
the country together he's just a bad
person guys there's that we don't need a
deeper analysis there's nothing else to
it people are dying
people's friends family members
colleagues are sick in the hospital and
Trump's joking around about a political
adversary having to self quarantine if
you ever feel like you just don't have
enough time to read all the books you
want to read you have to check out one
of my favorite apps called blinka splink
ax stakes thousands of popular
non-fiction books and distills each one
down into an e-book or audiobook that
you can get through in just 15 minutes
where you're getting all the key
takeaways from the book just imagine how
you'll be able to expand your horizons
and knowledge by being able to soak up
all of the important insights from ten
different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for or you can use it
to revisit a book you've already read or
use it to preview a book before you buy
the full version and read it I recently
read a brief history of time
of course by the great Stephen Hawking
this is a book that I have been aware of
for so long and other things got in the
way and it was fantastic to check it out
on blinkin
blink east has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about 8 bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video